anteriormente ya hice un vídeo sobre
esto y al menos intentaré darte la
intuición detrás sobre de dónde surge la
fórmula del equilibrio constante o de
dónde viene esta misma es decir de las
probabilidades de interacción de
diferentes moléculas si están en algún
volumen pequeño pero pienso que la vez
pasada utilice muchas cuentas con eso y
esto podría no haber sido tan claro
sobre cómo se relacionan las
probabilidades y las concentraciones así
que pensé que podía hacer en este vídeo
un ejercicio del mismo tipo pero hacerlo
con números reales con una reacción real
así que lo hice sin pensar en las a
veces hice es de la vez pasada lo que
escribí aquí es el proceso deja ver a
ver
ok y es justo como conseguimos amoniaco
en el mundo y como nos alimenta a todos
ya que el amoniaco es un fertilizante
muy importante pero eso no viene al caso
el proceso de javier el cual es justo
aquí está en equilibrio lo cual no
quiere decir que las concentraciones son
iguales de hecho esta es una
concentración en equilibrio que trabaje
antes de empezar el vídeo nota las
concentraciones de nitrógeno e hidrógeno
son muy diferentes a las concentraciones
de amoniaco la cual es mucho menor lo
que el equilibrio dice es que una vez
que tenemos esta concentración de
nitrógeno e hidrógeno la velocidad de
reacción que va en una dirección es la
misma que en ir en la dirección
contraria es decir es la misma velocidad
ir hacia la derecha que hacia la
izquierda cuando tenemos esta cantidad
de amoniaco así que vamos a pensar solo
sobre lo que es la velocidad de reacción
significa y entonces voy a poder decirte
cómo pienso todo esto al menos como lo
pienso es
un volumen muy pequeño y es más dejan
dibujarlo por aquí
imagínate que aquí me tomo un volumen
muy pequeño este va a ser mi volumen ok
vamos a tomarnos este de aquí ok y bueno
es un volumen muy pequeño porque voy a
decir que tenemos de volumen
o más bien tenemos aquí una altura de
debe de dv
la cual es una cantidad muy pero muy
pequeña y la forma en que esto trabaja
en mi cabeza es que si eliges algún
pequeño volumen en esta solución no
sabemos lo grande de la solución que en
realidad tenemos solo tenemos las
concentraciones en este volumen es tan
probable tener una reacción que vaya en
dirección directa como tener una
reacción que vaya en la dirección
contrario en la dirección hacia atrás
así que vamos a pensar sobre cuál es la
probabilidad de tener una reacción en
este volumen y la probabilidad
y bueno pensemos primero en la reacción
directa la probabilidad de
n 2 ok + 3 veces
h 2 ok esto va a ir en dirección directa
y voy a ponerlo justo así ok y ojo lo
que sea que haga en esta dirección
entonces solo tienes que usar la misma
lógica para la dirección contraria o
para atrás sólo quiero darte la
intuición de que esto es igual a una
constante relacionada con su
concentración así que la probabilidad de
ir en esta dirección y convertirnos en
esto que tenemos aquí en amoniaco así
que lo voy a poner con este color aunque
nos dé dos veces
nh3 ok justo esto de aquí y todo esto en
nuestra caja así que voy a ponerlo en el
color de la caja
nuestra caja en nuestra caja que tenemos
justo kim ok y ahora lo que quiero
decirte es que yo afirmó que esta
probabilidad esta va a ser igual o que
va a ser igual primero a la probabilidad
ok de que reaccionen dado que estén en
la caja y déjame ponerlo así reaccionen
acción en acción en ok dado dado que
estén en la caja que estén en la caja
la caja o que en esta caja que tengo
aquí dicho de otra manera una molécula
de nitrógeno que tiene dos átomos de
hidrógeno en él y tres moléculas de
hidrógeno si sabes que tienes estos
existe alguna probabilidad de que van a
reaccionar basadas en su configuración
su energía cinética y como están
aproximados unos con otros y todo este
tipo de cosas diferentes así que es la
probabilidad de que reaccionen dado que
están en esta pequeña caja de ven y
bueno a esto lo vamos a tener que
multiplicar claro por la probabilidad de
que bueno pues estén en la caja
la caja que estén en la caja y bueno
tiene toda la lógica del mundo ahora
esto que tengo aquí esto que tengo aquí
lo que también quiero afirmar es que es
una constante si sabes que a cierta
temperatura en el proceso de javier a
bueno de hecho es una temperatura de 300
grados celsius y si tú sabes que a esta
temperatura este proceso de javier se da
y bueno no es necesario memorizar esto
sólo lo he visto en algún lugar pero las
constantes de equilibrio se mantienen a
una cierta temperatura y te digo esto
porque estoy pretendiendo decirte que si
te duele una temperatura
digamos 300 grados celsius y si digo que
tengo una molécula de nitrógeno y tres
moléculas de hidrógeno en tu caja y que
hay una probabilidad constante de que
reaccionen
bueno pues todo esto depende de la
configuración y todo lo demás así que
llamaré a esto así que todo esto me da
pie a llamar a esto que tengo aquí a una
constante
de probabilidad pero bueno como estamos
hablando es la reacción directa lo voy a
poner como la constante de la reacción
la constante de la reacción ok y bueno
es que esto me está dando pie a déjame
bajar un poco la pantalla vamos a bajar
un poco la pantalla porque ya no tengo
espacio es decir que esto es exactamente
igual ok esto va a ser igual y bueno
ahora hay que preocuparnos en cuál es la
probabilidad que tenemos por estas
cuatro moléculas tres moléculas de
hidrógeno y una molécula de nitrógeno en
nuestra caja así que si queremos
averiguar que esto es igual a una
constante ok con ambos y esto va a ser
igual a una constante de reacción ok ya
esto lo voy a multiplicar por esta
probabilidad que tenemos en la caja por
la probabilidad de y bueno tenemos una
caja así que déjame dibujarla imagínate
que aquí me tomo mi caja a va a ser algo
así ok y vamos a dibujar esta parte para
acá
y esta va a ser mi caja esta parte para
acá ok
esta parte para acá ok y ahora juntamos
todos voy a contar este parte con esta
parte y esta parte con esta parte y ya
tenemos aquí a mi caja y bueno lo que
quiero saber es la probabilidad donde
esta caja es algún volumen muy pero muy
pequeño de tener a tres moléculas de
hidrógeno y déjame ponerlo con este
color quiero tres moléculas de hidrógeno
ok voy a tener aquí una molécula dos
moléculas tres moléculas de hidrógeno y
esto multiplicado por una molécula de
nitrógeno ya esto me voy a fijar también
en una molécula de nitrógeno ahora
debemos elegir una caja que sea lo
suficientemente pequeña ya que esto
indicaría que tan cerca necesitan estar
las moléculas para que reaccionen así
que yo elegiré una caja de dbm como
habíamos dicho vamos a ponerle aquí
dv pero bueno si queremos escoger una
longitud adecuada lo que podemos saber
es que el diámetro de una molécula
es un décimo del nanómetro así que
puedes poner 10 amoniacos justo por aquí
si esto fuera una caja de un nanómetro y
podrías tener 10 en cada dirección o
dicho de otra manera pueden caber 1000
si los empaques de una manera estrecha
ahora vamos a hacer esto con una
longitud un poco más pequeña vamos a
pensar en medio nanómetro en cada
dirección
entonces si digo que cada una de esta
longitud deben es una longitud muy
pequeña como de 0.5 ok nanómetros
nanómetros ok
bueno pues aquí también voy a tener 0.5
nanómetros ok y de este lado también voy
a tener 0.5 nanómetros de lujo y bueno
si elijo esta distancia entonces cuál es
mi volumen bueno de modo que nuestro
pequeño volumen nuestro pequeño volumen
quien va a ser bueno pues esto va a ser
lo mismo que 0.5
10 al menos 9 estos metros este de aquí
es un nanómetro 0.5 por 10 en al menos
nueve metros ok esto multiplicado por si
mismo tres veces es decir al cubo y
cuántos esto bueno pues esto es lo mismo
que un 5 por 5 25 por 5 125 y si yo
recorro el punto tres veces me va a
quedar 0.125 ok por 10 elevado a la 9
por 3 27 menos 27 ok metros ok
este es mi volumen de este pequeño pero
muy pequeño pero muy pequeño cubo que
tengo aquí ahora si nosotros pensamos en
la probabilidad de la caja quién es esta
probabilidad de la caja la probabilidad
de estar en la caja en la caja bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que pensar en la
probabilidad y bueno como necesitamos
tres hidrógenos esto va a ser lo mismo
que la probabilidad de tener un
hidrógeno en la caja
ok multiplicado por la probabilidad de
tener
otro hidrógeno en la caja ok a esto a su
vez multiplicado por la probabilidad de
tener otro hidrógeno en la caja ya esto
lo voy a multiplicar por la probabilidad
de tener un nitrógeno en la caca
necesito estas cuatro moléculas en la
caja ahora cuál es la probabilidad de
tener un hidrógeno en esta caja bueno
primero fijémonos en cuál era la
concentración y lo tengo justo por acá
arriba ok la concentración del hidrógeno
10 2 molar eso quiere decir y vamos a
bajar de nuevo la pantalla que si yo me
fijo en la concentración del hidrógeno y
déjame ponerlo así si yo me fijo en la
concentración del hidrógeno bueno pues
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 2 molar
ok o dicho de otra manera es lo mismo
que dos moles ok por litro ok
dos moles entre un litro y litro ok y
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo dos
moles este solamente es una constante
es lo mismo que dos que multiplican a 6
por 10 elevado a las 23 ok
está solamente es una constante ya esto
lo voy a dividir en lo que vale un litro
pero en metros cúbicos un litro en
metros cúbicos es lo mismo que 1 por 10
a la menos 3 metros cúbicos 1 por 10 a
la menos 3 ok metros cúbicos dicho de
otra manera caben mil litros en un metro
cúbico ok y si a esto lo multiplicamos y
ahora déjame cambiar de color
justo por esta cantidad que tengo aquí
la voy a multiplicar esto por nuestro
pequeño volumen que teníamos ok bueno
pues esto va a ser 0.125 ok por 10 a la
menos 27 ok estos en metros cúbicos
ok estos son metros cúbicos ojo y bueno
aquí lo que estoy diciendo es que esta
es la cantidad de metros cúbicos que
caben por cada uno de nuestros pequeños
de de de ok y ahora estoy expresando
esta concentración del hidrógeno con
respecto a este pequeño volumen o dicho
otra manera y si yo escribo así h 2 ok a
la concentración de h2 con respecto a
este pequeño volumen esto va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que y aquí podemos
simplificar cosas y bueno me quedaría 2
por 6 2 por 6 es 12 entre 1 es 12 x
0.125 40 saquemos nuestra calculadora y
voy a poner 12 que multiplica apuntó 125
ok esto es lo mismo que 1.5 de lujo
entonces me va a quedar 1.5 ok esto que
multiplica a 10 de la 23 por 10 en la
menos 27 me queda aquí 10 al menos 4 ok
entre 10 al menos 3 esto se convierte en
positivo y me va a quedar por 10 al
menos 1 estos metros cúbicos con estos
metros cúbicos se van y esta es la
concentración por cada
un pequeño que tenemos o dicho de otra
manera es lo mismo que 0.15 ok esta es
la cantidad de moléculas de hidrógeno
que tenemos por cada uno de estos
pequeños volúmenes y es más déjame
escribirlo moléculas moléculas ok
dm de hidrógeno y vamos a ponerlo con
este color de hidrógeno ok en este
pequeño volumen debe en este pequeño
volumen de ver
ok ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que esto está hablando de una
probabilidad porque obviamente no puedo
tener 0.15 moléculas en todas las cajas
sólo estoy diciendo en promedio
esto es 0.15 de posibilidad de tener una
molécula de hidrógeno en mi caja y bueno
es que esto me está diciendo si
regresamos a esto que tengo acá arriba
que entonces esta probabilidad es 0.15
ok esta de aquí también va a ser 0.15 ok
esta de aquí va a ser cero
punto 15 y bueno realmente lo que quiero
que veas este donde está saliendo este
0.15 este 0.15 lo sacamos de multiplicar
a esto que es la concentración del
hidrógeno y déjame ponerlo con un color
muy llamativo a esto que es la
concentración del hidrógeno aquí estamos
hablando de la concentración del
hidrógeno ok y lo único que hicimos fue
multiplicarlo esta es la concentración
del hidrógeno y lo único que hicimos fue
x este este que es una constante de
escala lo único que hicimos fue
escalarlo y este de aquí vamos a ponerlo
con otro color que también sea llamativo
esto de aquí lo podemos simplificar como
una constante una constante de escala
escala y bueno es que esto nos va a
servir porque ahora te puedo decir que
justo esta probabilidad que obtuvimos no
es ni más menos que pensar en am y
déjame ponerlo así que pensar en la
multiplicación de la concentración del
hidrógeno por
este factor que es a una constante de
escala de escala y es que esto me está
diciendo que estas probabilidades que
tengo aquí las puedo ver exactamente de
la misma manera esta probabilidad de
aquí es la concentración de h2 ok por
esta constante de escala ok
ésta también es la concentración del
hidrógeno por esta constante de escala y
este también es la concentración del
bueno si nosotros hacemos la misma idea
con el nitrógeno nosotros podríamos
llegar y fijarnos un poco más arriba en
qué es lo que pasa con este hidrógeno y
ver cuál de su concentración de hecho su
concentración es 1 molar es justo esto
que tenemos aquí pero 1 molar es la
mitad de la concentración que nosotros
teníamos del litro que no que era 2
molar por lo tanto hay dos formas de
pensarlo la primera es decir bueno nos
va a quedar
exactamente la mitad dicho de otra
manera esto es exactamente lo mismo que
multiplicar a esto por la mitad de 0.15
lo cual es 0 puntos 0.75 ok ok si
nosotros lo pensamos de una manera más
adecuada podemos decir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que la
concentración del nitrógeno ok
multiplicado por una constante de escala
y de hecho escalar ok y de hecho va a
ser exactamente la misma que esta
constante de escala
ahora si nosotros regresamos a nuestro
problema original este que tenemos acá
arriba ok
date cuenta que este problema nos dice
que tenemos la probabilidad de que
reaccionen dado de que estén en la caja
por la probabilidad que tenemos en la
caja en esta probabilidad era una
constante la constante de la acción por
la probabilidad de que estemos en la
caja que es justo lo que acabamos de
obtener aquí abajo y entonces vamos a
escribirlo tengo a esta constante que
multiplica y dejemos utilizar este color
que va a multiplicar
te das cuenta tenemos a la concentración
del hidrógeno ok que multiplica a una
constante y vamos a llamar la constante
en escalar constante escalar ok esto que
a su vez multiplica otra vez a la
concentración del hidrógeno que a su vez
multiplica a otra constante escalar ok
esto aunque a su vez multiplica a otra
vez a esta concentración del hidrógeno
ok estamos justo aquí que multiplica a
esta constante escalar ok y esto a su
vez que multiplica a esta parte de aquí
que es la concentración del nitrógeno ok
vamos a ponerlo así la concentración del
nitrógeno que multiplica a esa misma
constante escalar ok y ahora si nosotros
multiplicamos todas las constantes y nos
damos cuenta que realmente lo que
estábamos buscando era la probabilidad
de esta reacción de la reacción directa
en nuestra caja entonces vamos a bajar
la pantalla para concluir si nosotros
ponemos aquí justo a esto
voy a decir que la probabilidad la
probabilidad de la reacción directa
directa en la caja
jaja ok esto a quien va a ser igual
bueno pues multiplico una constante por
una constante por una constante por una
constante pues eso nos da una constante
y lo voy a poner como la constante
directa la constante directa que al
final está me va a multiplicar a la
concentración a la concentración del
hidrógeno esto elevado a la tercera
potencia porque se está multiplicando
tres veces recuerdan y esto multiplicado
esto multiplicado por la concentración
del nitrógeno de lujo ahora si nosotros
queremos ir en dirección contraria es
decir fijarnos en la reacción inversa si
pensamos en la probabilidad de la
función inversa
ok pues siguiendo la misma lógica y no
voy a hacer todas las cuentas que hice
justo ahorita esto va a ser igual a una
constante y si nosotros subimos a un
poco la pantalla recordando cuál era
la constante que nosotros estábamos
buscando ok bueno pues recuerda en
primer lugar que aquí solamente tenemos
al amoniaco y de hecho este amoniaco
tiene como coeficiente al 2 así que
vamos a bajar la pantalla y entonces
para no puede escribir todo esto para el
amoniaco
nosotros podemos concluir que es una
constante y la voy a poner como
constante inversa ok que multiplica y
vamos a ponerlo con este color que
multiplica a la concentración del
amoniaco nh3 esto elevado a la segunda
potencia porque ese era su coeficiente
este cromático y bueno lo padre de todo
esto es que cuando estamos en equilibrio
estas dos son iguales así que déjenme
atraparlas y copiarlas porque estábamos
en una reacción que está en equilibrio
ok voy a pegar está por aquí ok ya está
la voy a ser igual a esta de aquí ok voy
a atraparla también a ok y la voy a
pegar justo por aquí ok y vamos a hacer
las iguales porque
estamos en equilibrio estas dos van a
ser iguales y si ahora bajo un poco más
la pantalla para decirte que nosotros
vamos a dividir todo y bueno justo en
este momento es cuando no recuerdo bien
cuáles son los productos que deben de
quedar en el lado correcto de la
ecuación así que vamos a tomar esto voy
a pasar esta de aquí para acá ok y voy a
pasar esto de aquí para acá y que me va
a quedar bueno si ahora lo escribo de la
siguiente manera tengo acá y con este
color lo voy a poner así la constante de
reacción inversa entre la constante de
reacción directa ok estoy dividiendo
todo entre esta constante esto va a ser
igual y de este lado me queda esta parte
de aquí es más déjeme atraparla ok y la
voy a copiar el lado de pegar ok justo a
esta parte que tengo aquí dividida ok
entre esta parte que tengo aquí así que
déjenme hacerlo con este color dividido
esto a su vez está dividido entre
la concentración del amoniaco ok esto
elevado a la segunda potencia y ahora si
te das cuenta que justo esto que tengo
aquí es una constante por lo tanto y lo
puedo poner como cualquier constante
techo lo voy a llamar la constante de
equilibrio entonces ya tengo justo la
fórmula de la constante de equilibrio
que yo quería una fórmula pseudo
derivada de este equilibrio constante y
bueno esto es todo al menos en mi mente
proviene del sentido común de la
probabilidad de que si tienes un pequeño
volumen las cosas van a reaccionar